if somebody goes to a restaurant for the
first time and has a flawless experience
the statistical likelihood of them doing
a second visit is about 40 percent they
come here I believe that in design and
have flawless experience the statistical
likelihood of a third visit is still
about 42 percent the third time they
come the statistical likelihood of a
fourth visit is over 70% so I've got a
market - three visits not one visit one
from rib dinner if you sit him down put
a red napkin on a table not a white one
identify them as a first-time customer
connect with them and work to get them
back a second time in the third time
once they're there the third time you
own them my ultimate the red napkin
thing is genius moly because you know
the fast-casual environment we're not
hitting that table money but let me give
you from your back it's riddle chair let
me my detail that no God okay so you put
a red napkin at the table Gary sits down
he's eating dinner now he's getting his
free rib dinner orders water cost of
nothing I know you're a first-time
customer because he's got a red napkin
when he's leaving a manager comes to the
table writes on the back of the business
card five dollars off chicken did you
like the ribs love them you gotta try my
chicken come in for the chicken now I'm
prompting a second visit not with a
printing I tried a hand grab card now he
comes in a second visit drops the
business card on the table everybody
knows this is the second visit because
red napkin was the first visit second
visit Martinez de Mille you go if you
say so how is the chicken it was quick
and great are you full totally stuffed
man next time you got to try my
cheesecake peas free piece of cheesecake
now three visits risk we obviously a
piece of cake I thought a pizza not
labor cheesecake I was like that's
[ __ ] brilliant so the rib dinner
cause we've got ours the chicken washout
decimated discounts right the cheesecake
is a dollar thirty five for about six
hours you got three visits out of them
with a seventy percent likelihood of a
fourth that's the way you market a
restaurant with that more walnut that is
that is that is that is HUGE right
that's what you through the best cheer
let me listen let me give you one more
for the road mister
it was a very interesting thing that
John said because I grew up in that
environment too and John's from the
traditional marketing world that we grew
up in from pulling from his world notice
how he said first time customer I'll
give it to you because the traditional
retail and bar thing is like look it
works but like you've already got
somebody in the funnel the cost of
acquisition for a new buddy is very very
very powerful I used to do that too but
it was tricky right because now some of
your old time customers may see that and
they've got that angst of wait a minute
why am I being not treated that way as a
loyal customer
you just want new people and it's always
been a friction for us right in the week
right now
I just went to Instagram right I tucked
in Lexington Kentucky got it yes sir
I'm looking at nine posts right now
better top posts and ungodly amounts
unlimited amounts of people's posts are
from Lexington Kentucky I went down all
the way down and that's from 48 minutes
ago 40 pictures down 48 minutes ago
thousands of people are posting right
now on Instagram from Lexington Kentucky
I go to the top nine posts I click the
middle one it's a nice little cute
couple
right they got 298 likes Abby she's got
she's from somewhere she's part of a
sorority it looks like she has 2387
followers there's a triple bot in the
top right corner on Instagram I hit it
and let me send her a message I send her
a message a b c or lexington we love
being part of lexington here's a $20 off
coupon $10 off coupon free chicken only
she sees it you're grabbing somebody who
has a big social media profile you've
not heard any of your loyal customers
like me and John had to back in the day
she comes and she posts a picture of the
food and creates word-of-mouth now that
five dollar acquisition created no
friction two loyal customers and because
she's now media she amplifies it and
you're getting an eighty five hundred
four thousand dollar media amplification
against your five [ __ ] dollars and
last one thing don't discount people get
addicted to discounts they don't get
addicted to free
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]